is enough times to know where he's
coming from there is actually a majority
of um of tory mps on that committee and
although some of them are not always
entirely sympathetic uh to boris johnson
looking at the list uh list of names on
it there are some more moderate figures
some who've been privately critical of
him they would still have to vote for
instance to call the prime minister as a
witness to call for evidence photographs
against pretty heavy pressure from
conservative whips so even if this
investigation does take place by the
privileges committee it seems to me far
from clear that it's going to be as
exciting as the opposition want it to be
i know that there was a huge amount of
agonizing inside kirsten's office about
whether or not to even to go ahead with
this because there's nothing that unites
the conservative party quicker than
attacked by their enemies and attacked
by kirstama weaponizing as they would
see it the institutions of parliament to
make a partisan a party political point
uh and so there was fear inside
kirsten's office that even doing this uh
could in some way help bring together a
a conservative party that has been
pretty fractious through the course of
this year but it does seem to me that to
get the kinds of things that the
opposition really want this committee to
do get hold of photographs get hold of
evidence come to a conclusion that the
prime minister's lied and then have a
vote on that in the floor of the house
well sarah j there just seemed to be so
many hurdles before uh the privileges
committee uh will achieve that aim but
also bluntly as we were saying earlier i
just think now is not the time
politically you do have this mismatch
it's an important moment there's no
doubt about it that boris johnson's
coming to the house for the first time
since he became the first sitting prime
minister to be fined for breaking the
law along with his chancellor along with
his wife
and so it is a big moment in that sense
and there will be theater and the
language that he uses is important but
because of the political moment because
we're just a few weeks away from the
local elections because we don't know
how many fines the police are going to
issue against boris johnson personally
and there is speculation amongst
government figures that could be two uh
or three more given just how low some of
them uh believe that the police have set
uh the um
the hurdles um and because uh we don't
know quite how this is all going to play
out uh with the su grey report the top
official is going to look into all of uh
the goings on uh over 2020 2021 and then
uh try and
reconstruct the story and perhaps hint
at some of the blame it's only when all
of that has happened that really we're
gonna get the verdict so there are
committees there is this vote on
thursday boris johnson won't even be
there for it other ministers aren't
going to be there for it either they've
judged its risk um there's enough is
enough of a low risk to uh to not turn
up on thursday uh that i think that
we've got uh that that that i think we
can assume that the tory whips the tory
uh machine the tory hierarchy don't
think this week is the moment of danger
the biggest effect the biggest impact it
could do is just to re-uh
to remind voters uh of partygate of all
of the things that they saw through
january and february that rather dropped
off the agenda for the very
understandable reason uh that we've been
dealing with the invasion uh the russian
invasion of ukraine just remind them of
what happened as they prepare to go
to the ballot boxes for a series of
elections that frankly um when they when
they come at the first week of may no no
none of the political academics that i
speak to particularly certain quite what
it's going to look like it might end up
being quite good for the conservatives
it might end up being quite good for the
labour party
but having there's no doubt that having
party gate thrust front and center back
into people's minds uh just with a
couple of weeks two three weeks to go
until polling day is unhelpful
for the conservative party even though
these elections of course are for a
disparate range of different
institutions local councils london
councils
shires
scottish councils where the question on
the ballot paper is a lot going to be to
do with uh the snp and how they're doing
and then over in northern ireland where
there's incredible constitutional
wrangle that could end up with no
assembly being formed after elections
and possibly even with the dup uh in
second place after those elections so
you've got a huge sweep of issues being
dealt with uh in those local elections
but i do think that there's a few tory
mps that would that would suggest uh
that having um the events of the 19th of
june 2020 when boris johnson uh uh
wandered into the cabinet room to be uh
ambushed by cake or the cake stay stayed
in tupperware or whatever quite happened
in that room we don't have the uh we
have conflicting uh accounts maybe boris
johnson will clear it up for us in a few
moments time but um to have that isn't
helpful which is why allies are the
prime minister uh saying to me this
afternoon that the number one job when
boris johnson gets to his feet
is to find a way of apologizing and then
contextualizing that's their word
contextualizing quite what he previously
told
parliament now translation of that is
try to get out of what other people are
accusing him of doing that would have
been a lie uh because of course he said
that there weren't any uh rules broken
uh now clearly the police have judged
otherwise one of the big jobs he's got
uh today is to try and wiggle out of
that accusation that that meant that he
lied to parliament in december in 2021
uh january 2022
and it's that attempt to contextualize i
think uh that will be critical to the
hearing essentially saying things i
suspect like look i did go into the
cabinet room as the police alleged there
was a gathering that was illegal i um
don't uh dispute the police judgment but
you've got to understand that it was the
ninth engagement of the day um i'd
already been on a school's video i'd
already been dealing with a series of
pandemic meetings i've chaired the
pandemic task force and then i just knew
there was an event that i needed to go
into in the cabinet room i knew the
chance it was going to be there that's
why i went there i didn't realize
that i was breaking the law now
uh with boris johnson clearly coming in
uh to the chamber here uh i think we're
just about to hear what he has to say
to make his statement prime minister
[Music]
thank you mr speaker with permission
i'll update the house on the
government's response to events at home
and abroad during the easter recess
i will come to ukraine in a moment since
i've just left a virtual meeting with
president biden uh president macron
chancellor schultz and eight other
world leaders but let me
begin
in all humility by saying
that on the 12th of april
i received a fixed penalty notice
relating to an event in downing street
on the 19th of june
2020
i paid the fine
immediately
and i offered the british people a full
apology
and i take this opportunity
on the first available sitting day
to repeat my wholehearted apology to the
house
[Music]
as soon as i received the notice
i acknowledged the hurt
and the anger
and i said that people had a right
to expect better
of their
prime minister
and i repeat that mr speaker again
in the house now
let me also say
not by way
of mitigation
or excuse me
but purely
purely because it explains my previous
words in this house that it did not
occur to me then
or subsequently
that a gathering in the cabinet room
just before a vital meeting on covet
strategy
could amount
to a breach of the
rules i repeat
that was my
mistake
and i apologize for it
unreservedly
i respect the outcome of the police
investigation which is still
underway
and i can only say that i will respect
their decision-making and always take
the appropriate steps and as the house
will know i have already taken
significant steps to change the way
things work in number ten
and it is precisely because i know
that so many people are angry
and disappointed
that i feel an even greater sense of
obligation to deliver
on the priorities of the british people
and to respond in the best traditions of
our country
to putin's barbaric onslaught against
ukraine
our ukrainian friends are fighting for
the life of their nation
and they achieved the greatest feat of
arms of the 21st century by repelling
the russian assault on kiev
and the whole house will share my
admiration for their heroism and courage
putin arrogantly assumed that he would
capture kiev in a matter of days
and now the blackened carcasses of his
tanks and heavy armor litter the
approaches to the capital on both banks
of the denipa
and are smoldering monuments
to his failure
having pulverized the invaders armored
spearheads the ukrainians then
counter-attacked and by the 6th of april
putin had been compelled to withdraw his
forces from the entire kiev region
britain and our allies supplied some of
the weaponry
but it was ukrainian valor and sacrifice
which saved their capital
i traveled to kiev myself
on the 9th of april
the first g7 leader to visit since the
invasion
and i spent four hours
with president vladimir zelensky
the indomitable leader of a nation
fighting for survival who gives the roar
of a lionhearted people
i assured him of the implacable resolve
of the united kingdom
shared across this house to join with
our allies
and give his brave people the weapons
they need to defend themselves
when the president and i went for an
impromptu walk through central kiev
we happened upon a man who immediately
expressed his love
uh for britain and the british people
and he was generous enough to say quite
unprompted i should reassure the house i
will tell my children and grandchildren
they must always remember that britain
helped us
but the urgency is even greater now
because putin has
regrouped his forces and launched a new
offensive in the donbass we knew
this danger would come
and when i welcomed president dude of
poland to dining street on the 7th of
april and chancellor schultz the
following day we discussed exactly how
we could provide the arms that ukraine
would desperately need to counter
putin's next onslaught
on the 12th of april i spoke to
president biden to brief him on my visit
to kiev and how we will intensify our
support for president zielinski and i
propose that our long-term goal must be
to strengthen and fortify ukraine to the
point where russia will never dare
to invade again
just as our foreign policy must look to
the long term the same is true of this
government's domestic priorities and as
we face the economic aftershocks of
kovid and the consequences of russian
aggression that is above all in tackling
the impact on british energy prices and
on consumers and on family bills and
that's why we're spending over nine
billion pounds to help families
struggling with their bills we're
helping families to insulate their homes
and reduce costs and to end our
dependence on putin's oil and gas
and to ensure that energy is cheaper in
the long term we publish on the 7th of
april a new strategy to make british
energy greener more affordable and more
secure we will massively expand offshore
wind and in the country that split the
atom we will build a new reactor not
every decade but every year this
government is joining with our allies to
face down putin's aggression abroad
while addressing the toughest problems
at home helping millions of families
with the cost of living making our
streets safer and funding the nhs to
clear the covid backlog
my job is to work every day to make the
british people
safer more secure and more prosperous
and that is what i will continue to do
and i commend this statement to the
house
we don't come to the leader of the
opposition kiss armor
what a joke
even now
as the latest merely mouthed apology
stumbles out of one side of his mouth
a new set of deflections and distortions
poor from the other
but the damage is already done
the public have made up their mind
they don't believe a word the prime
minister says
they know what he is
as ever with this prime minister those
close to him find themselves ruined and
the institutions he vows to protect
damaged
good ministers forced to walk away from
public service
the chancellor's career up in flames
and the leader of the scottish
conservatives rendered pathetic
for all those unfamiliar with this prime
minister's career
this isn't some
fixable glitch in the system
it's the whole point
it's what he does
it's who he is
he knows he's dishonest and incapable of
changing
so he drags everybody else down with him
the more people deface themselves
parroting
order i can't hear what's being said
because you're making joke
mr fabric i'm all right
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
dishonest i don't think that's an
appropriate word
i think
we don't want to talk about breaking
rules do we i don't think that's a good
time to discuss i just say i think he
just withdraws that and works around and
i'm sure that with the knowledge that
he's gained over many many years he can
use appropriate words there is in
keeping with good temperament language
of this house
mr speaker
i respect that ruling from the chair the
prime minister knows what he is
[Music]
and so
he drags everyone else down with him the
more people debase themselves parroting
his absurd defenses
the more the public will believe all
politicians are the same all as bad as
each other
and that suits this prime minister just
fine
some members opposite seem oblivious to
the prime minister's game
some know what he's up to
but are too weak to act
but others are gleefully playing the
part the prime minister cast for them
a minister on the radio this morning
saying
it's the same as a speeding ticket
no it's not no one has ever broken down
in tears because they couldn't drive
faster than 20 miles an hour outside a
school don't insult the public with this
nonsense
but mr speaker as it happens
the last minister who got a speeding
ticket and then lied about it ended up
in prison and i know because i
prosecuted him
[Applause]
[Music]
and last week last week we were treated
to a grotesque spectacle one of the
prime minister's loyal supporters
accusing teachers and nurses of drinking
in the staff room during lockdown
[Applause]
members opposites can associate
themselves with that if they want
but those of us who take pride in our
nhs workers
our teachers
and every other key worker who got us
through those dark days will never
forget their contempt
plenty didn't agree with every rule the
prime minister wrote
but they followed them nonetheless
because in this country
we respect others
we put the greater good above narrow
self-interest
and we understand
that the rules apply to all of us
this morning i spoke to john robinson
a constituent of the member for
litchfield
i want to tell you his story
when his wife died of covet
john and his family obeyed the prime
minister's rules
he didn't see her in
hospital he didn't hold her hand as she
died
their daughters and grandchildren drove
a hundred miles up the motorway
clutching a letter from the funeral
director in case they were questioned by
the
police they didn't have a service in the
church
john's son-in-law stayed away
because he would have been the forbidden
seventh mourner
doesn't the prime minister realize
that john would have given the world
to hold his dying wife's hand
even if it was just for nine minutes
but he didn't
because he followed the prime minister's
rules
rules that we now know the prime
minister blithely repeatedly and
deliberately ignored
after months
of insulting excuses
today's half-hearted apology will never
be enough for john robinson
if the prime minister had any respect
for john
and the millions like him who sacrificed
everything to follow the rules
he'd resign
because he doesn't respect john
he doesn't respect the sacrifice of the
british public
he is a man without shame
looking past the member for litchfield
and the nodding dogs in the cabinet
there are many decent honorable members
on the benches opposite
who do respect john robinson who do
respect the british public
they know the damage the prime minister
is doing
they know things can't go on as they are
and they know
it's their responsibility to bring an
end to this shameful chapter
today i urge them once again
don't follow in the slipstream of an out
of touch out of control prime minister
put their conscience first
put their country first
put john robinson first
and remove the prime minister from
office
bring decency honesty and integrity back
into our politics
and stop the denigration of everything
that this country stands for
[Music]
sir william prime minister mr speaker i
apologize once again
profusely to
to john robinson to all those
uh who lost loved ones particularly
those
who suffered during the the pandemic and
mr speaker in my statement i have
tried to explain why i spoke to the
house as i did the right honourable
gentleman has chosen to uh to respond
with a a series of uh personal attacks
on me and i understand why he uh why he
does that uh but i think it and i i
understand that mr speaker but i think
it would have been a good thing
if in the course of his remarks he had
addressed some of the uh issues that i
mentioned uh not least the crisis in
ukraine uh
with the impact that that is having on
the livelihoods of everybody in this
country
and it is to address that uh that this
government will get on with our job mr
speaker it is to focus on the needs of
the british people and when he talks
about nodding dogs mr speaker uh i'd
remind the house that there was a
certain nodding dog who sat nodding oh
in the previous uh labor administer the
previous labor shadow cabinet mr speaker
that would happily have installed uh the
right the honourable member uh for
islington north and made i think a
disastrous mistake in the security of
our country at a very difficult time
this country this government will get on
with the with the difficult job of
taking us
through
the aftershocks of the kovid pandemic
leading not just this country but i
think uh the world in our response uh to
the violence that we're seeing in
ukraine i i must say uh that i i renew
my apologies i renew my apologies to to
john robertson to families up and down
the land but i think the best thing that
we can do now for this country as
politicians is is not to indulge in the
personal abuse of the kind that we've
heard and to get on with our jobs
so william cash uh thank you mr speaker
um having heard the remarks both of my
right honourable friend and the leader
of the opposition
may i put it to the house that
my right honourable friend i'm sure
appreciates
that
it is crystal clear that a fixed penalty
notice such as in his own case is a
civil penalty fine which if paid within
28 days
eliminates future prosecution in the
criminal courts and furthermore without
any admission of guilt in a recent
criminal case in a recent criminal
appeal case
and in that judgment
it was said that if the payment was made
within those 28 days a fixed penalty
notice was held not to be a conviction
as the defendant to quote the court's
judgment quote was not admitting an
offense or criminality and would have no
stain imputed to his character that is
the perspective and that is the
case prime minister
[Applause]
all right uh mr speaker i want to make
it absolutely clear that i in no way
minimize the importance of this fine uh
i i am heartily sorry for my mistake and
i uh accept completely uh the decision
of the police
leader of the smp in blackford
[Applause]
thank you mr speaker
let us remind ourselves
on the 8th of december last year
the prime minister
denied
that any parties happened in 10 downing
street
they are the very same parties
that the police
have now fined
the prime minister for attending
by now people know that the rules of
this house
prevent me from saying
that the prime minister deliberately and
willfully misled this house
but maybe today that matters little
because the public have already made up
their minds
yougov polling shows 75 of the british
public and 82 percent of people in
scotland have made their minds up on the
prime minister
the public knows
the difference
between the truth
and lying here
and they know
that the prime minister
is only apologizing
for one reason
and one reason only
it's the only reason he ever apologizes
because he's been caught
after months of denials
his excuses have finally run out of road
and so must his time in office
the prime minister
has broken the very laws he wrote
to try and argue that he did not know he
had broken his own laws
would be laughable
if it wasn't so serious
prime minister you can't hide behind
advisors he knows
we know
that the dogs in the street know
that the prime minister has broken the
law
this is the first prime minister
to be officially found to have broken
the law in office
a law-breaking prime minister
just dwell on this a prime minister who
has broken the law
and remains under investigation
over additional lawbreaking
not just a law breaker a serial offender
if he has any decency
any dignity he would not just apologize
he would resign
yes
mr speaker
the scale and the seriousness of the
issues we are all now facing demand
effective leadership from a prime
minister who can be trusted
the tory cost of living crisis and the
war crimes being inflicted on the
ukrainian people need our full focus in
a time of crisis the very least the
public deserves
is a prime minister they can trust to
tell the truth
and for this prime minister
that trust is broken
and it can never be fixed
the truth is
that a majority of people across these
islands will never trust a single word
he says again
so the questions today are not so much
for a prime minister desperately
clinging on to power the real question
is for tony back benches
will they finally grow a spine and
remove this person from office
or is the tory strategy to go on about
standing behind the prime minister who
the public can't trust
with the truth
[Applause]
well mr speaker director right on my
journey what i said earlier i i
apologize uh profusely for uh my mistake
and for what i uh have got wrong and i i
repeat that uh he he asks about uh
whether this government is capable of
reprinting providing effective
leadership during the current uh crisis
i uh and in in standing up to russia and
i would just remind him that i think it
is still the policy of the scottish
national party uh to dispense with his
country's independent nuclear deterrent
at a particularly crucial time i don't
think that's what this country needs
right now
john whittingdale many of my
constituents are angry about breaches
which happened two years ago and i
welcome the prime minister's recognition
of that and his apology but does he
agree that we currently face the gravest
crisis in our global security for a long
time and it is essential that we remain
focused
on beating putin and stopping the
aggression against ukraine can he say
what additional measures we can now give
to ukraine following his discussion with
president biden and others to ensure
that putin's aggression cannot be
allowed to succeed
i i thank my right old friend and i i i
repeat my uh my
apologies my contrition but i want to
say on the
uh
the state of the war in ukraine it's at
a very perilous stage and it is vital
now that we uh don't allow putin to gain
momentum in the in the donbass as he as
he well could uh and in the east and
that's why uh we are stepping up our
supply of military hardware of a kind
that i think the ukrainians particularly
need now uh this will become an
artillery conflict they need support
with more artillery uh that is what we
will be uh giving them mr speaker in
addition to many other forms of support
dave margaret hodge thank you speaker i
i see that the prime minister is anxious
to move on to other issues and i think
the question is can he do that
and i would take one example can he
perhaps explain to me to the house and
to the country how he can credibly
justify on the one hand calling for the
resignation of the boss of piano ferries
when he faced allegations that he broke
the law while on the other hand refusing
to resign when he himself is guilty
of actually breaking the law he said
[Applause]
i thank her very much and uh i think
that what the piano ferries did was
entirely uh wrong
as i've told the as i've told the house
uh before and i think and i think by the
way uh that i made a serious mistake and
i apologize for it very sincerely
mark
mark oprah
speaker i strongly support the
government's actions uh in standing up
to putin's aggression and helping
ukraine defend itself
and our values and it's exactly at times
like this
that our country needs a prime minister
who exemplifies
those values
i regret to say
that we have a prime minister who broke
the laws that he told the country they
had to follow
hasn't been straightforward about it and
is now going to ask the men and the
decent men and women on this these
benches to defend what i think is
indefensible
i'm very sorry to have to say this but i
no longer think he is worthy of the
great office that he holds
[Applause]
well i i
must say to my uh right horrible friend
i i know the
uh the care and the sincerity with which
he uh which he weighs his words and i
i bitterly regret uh what has happened i
bitterly regret
the
the event in uh in downing street as i
have said but i do believe that it is
the job of this government to get on
with the priorities of the british
people and that is what we're going to
do
speaker a poll over the weekend asked 2
000 people
what they think of the prime minister
the most common word they used by far
was liar
does the prime minister understand how
profoundly damaging it is to our great
country
to have a government
led by a man
the public no longer trust
and no longer have confidence in
mr speaker if the prime minister won't
resign
will he at least give conservative mps
on thursday a free vote
so conservative peas can decide for
themselves
whether the prime minister deliberately
misled parliament
or was just so incompetent
that he didn't even understand his own
laws
mr speaker i i repeat what i've said
earlier i disagree profoundly with what
he's uh with what he's just said uh but
i repeat my apology to the house and to
enter the country jake barry
thank you mr speaker the people of
roslindale and darwin will have weighed
the words of the prime minister
carefully listening to them today and
they will like me feel that it is a
contrite
and wholehearted apology
they will also be
looking at the action of the prime
minister
in ukraine
and i wonder if he would consider
putting britain
at the forefront
of a new marshall plan
to rebuild ukraine after putin has been
defeated
and fund this in part
by the assets confiscated by the russian
by the british state from russian
oligarchs
uh can i thank my right honourable
friend for his excellent suggestion it's
one uh indeed that the uk government is
already uh pursuing and in my
conversations with president uh zolensky
we did discuss exactly how uh the
supporters and friends of ukraine around
the world can help to rebuild that
beautiful country when the conflict is
over what's in culture
mr speaker we've always known haven't we
that he was only ever sorry
because he was caught
banned
and this latest spin about the met
having it wrong
is designed to bully the met
and to provide cover
to his back benchers that haven't got
the bottle to sack him
but the country has already concluded
that he's either a liar
or an idiot sorry sorry oh
i said we've got template language when
we have the motion on thursday that is a
different matter for today we're not
using language language
that's the thing i withdraw
the word liar
mr speaker but the electorate
will have already decided
but what everybody knows
what everybody knows
is that he is a law breaker yeah so if
the met have got the wrong end of the
stick
why doesn't he challenge these penalties
before the criminal courts
have his day in court yeah
yeah um i i thank the honourable
government very much and uh i just want
to repeat what i said in my statement
earlier which is i fully respect the
decision of the police
dr julian lewis
does my right honorable friend have the
power
to authorize sue gray to publish her
report in full
and if so
will he use that power in order to put
an end to this matter so that we do not
get diverted away as we are being from
such crucial question as supplying
armaments to ukrainian democrats
i thank uh my right honourable friend
very much but i think it very important
that the uh met should conclude their uh
investigation before uh the subreddit's
final report
today marks the prime minister's
thousandth day in office
it takes a particular type of prime
minister to rack up as many catastrophic
failures scandals as u-turns as days on
the
job from the tory made cost of living
crisis dodgy coveted contracts for his
cronies
unlawfully proroguing parliament and now
breaking the law
enough is enough so will the prime
minister confirm
if this
thousandth day will be his life
well i might add a list uh mr speaker
nothing
rolling out rolling out the fastest
vaccine program anywhere in europe mr
speaker thereby by accomplishing the
fastest economic growth in the g7 mr
speaker and leading the world and
standing up to putin mr speaker
[Applause]
thank you
thank you mr speaker
um i
appreciate the prime minister coming
here today um and taking full
responsibility and apologizing
um but
it is very clear mr speaker repeatedly
um president zielinski has identified
the prime minister as ukraine's greatest
ally he's also been identified i think
by president putin as enemy number one
does the prime minister agree that this
isn't a bad athlete to have and doesn't
he also agree that mumps a psycho drama
in here would play into hands of the
latter not the former
think it's very important mr speaker
that uh uh the people in this country
should understand i although the
uh the country is faced with massive
issues that we have to deal with
including the aftershocks of copenhagen
and the uh the war in uh in ukraine uh
uh i in no way minimize the importance
of uh the fine i have received and i
apologize wholeheartedly
quickly
thank you very much mr speaker
i think people across the house
uh would agree that the situation in
ukraine is a very serious one
and there's no doubt we fully support uh
you know what's going on and what what
we're trying to do
but setting that aside for a minute the
prime minister stands before us today as
the first residence of number 10 to be
found guilty of breaking the law while
serving in public office
and while he's finally apologized today
it's been accompanied by the absurd
caveat that the man who stepped the
rules couldn't understand them
well the prime minister could see that
him remaining office would deal a
grievous blow to the rule of law in this
country and for the first time in his
career will he put the national interest
before his personal ambition and resign
[Applause]
i i thank you very much i repeat my
apology i direct him to what i've said
uh earlier on and i think the uh what
the people this country need is us
focusing on their issues and their
priorities and that's what the
government is going to do holly member
croft thank you
can i thank the prime minister for the
update he's given this afternoon on the
uh energy security strategy and
particularly for the support that this
offers for steel it is the latest in a
long line of support that the prime
minister has brought forward also sets
out plans on wind solar and nuclear does
he agree with me that the best possible
place to make the steel needed for these
projects is right here in the uk yeah
yeah yeah
yes and she she is completely right and
that's why our energy security strategy
is so absolutely vital not just for uh
consumers but also for british industry
richard bergen
thank you mr speaker a new poll shows
three quarters of the public think the
prime minister deliberately lied about
breaking lockdown rules yet on thursday
the prime minister will order his mps to
stop his law breaking ever coming before
the privileges committee if the prime
minister has nothing to hide why didn't
he do the straightforward thing and
refer himself to the privileges
committee what's the prime minister
scared of
mr speaker the house will decide
[Music]
peter bond uh thank you mr speaker may i
thank the prime minister for coming to
the house at the earliest opportunity to
update us on this situation
on thursday sir following your
announcements this morning this house
has got to decide whether to refer the
prime minister to the privileged
commission privileges committee there is
only one issue
did the prime minister deliberately
mislead the house could i ask the prime
minister
did you deliberately mislead the house
at the dispatch folks
no mr speaker
sammy wilson
prime minister
there will be millions of angry
people across the united kingdom today
even after the apology which has been
given here today who will still remain
angry because of what they've gone
through but i think that any objective
listener today will recognize that for
whatever reason the
apology given today was a genuine
apology
and that we
we now need
and that
there are hundreds of thousands of
unionists in northern ireland who are
angry about other things as well that
that happened but
rather than focus on the past i think
that's important we focus on the future
and
the prime minister has said that he
discussed today
the situation in ukraine with world
leaders
that situation is becoming very
desperate
what discussions has he had about giving
the appropriate weaponry to the
ukrainian forces so that they can drive
back the russians liberate their country
and avoid all of the consequences
whether it's in terms of our economy oil
or food for the rest of the world
i i thank you very much and as as he
knows the uh the uk is in continuous
discussion with the ukrainians about
what we can do to help them uh defend
themselves and a lot more has a lot has
gone a lot more will be going while i'm
at it i want to pay tribute to a
particular northern ireland uh business
used to be short brothers nitalis that
has been absolutely indispensable as he
knows in helping the ukrainians against
russian armour john barron
mr speaker the government and british
people have provided extensive support
to ukrainian refugees but they remain in
afghanistan around 200 british council
contractors who many of whom are fleeing
from the taliban i'm awaiting a meeting
with the refugee minister one that was
promised back in november will he use
his good offices to speed that meeting
along
i thank him very much and yes of course
and those 200 contractors for the
british council should i i believe
automatically be uh eligible and
certainly should be able to come under
our uh the scheme that we we put in
place but i'll make sure he gets the
meeting he wants
crispr
thank you mr speaker as chair of the
all-party group on russia
i found it very difficult this easter to
have any faith seeing the barbarity
meted out to the people of ukraine
women tortured
raped
their children tortured and raped
their men folk in many cases their hands
tied and then shot in the back of the
head all of these we
know to be war crimes
but many of these worst atrocities have
been committed by sociopaths working as
mercenaries paid for by the russian
government by the russian state
but nonetheless working as mercenaries
the uk still isn't a signatory to the
convention on mercenaries isn't it time
we put
a stop to this terrible barbarity not
just in ukraine but in other places in
the world where mercenaries from the
wagner group
operate with sociopathic intent
i i was i thank him very much and
i i think you're right i will study his
proposal on uh on mercenaries and i i
just i say to him that i think he's been
uh right for a long time on russia and
he's been he's been vindicated
so jeffrey clifton brown thank you mr
speaker i've heard the fulsome apology
by the prime minister
but what he is doing is taking a lead in
ukraine and what he needs to do if i may
suggest is keep giving ukraine defensive
weapons so that we can eventually drive
president putin and the russian
federation to a peace agreement and then
will he lead the world in gaining
reparations so that that great country
can be rebuilt again
i i i thank him very much and uh i thank
him for his uh his staunch position on
uh ukraine uh he's he's completely right
i'm afraid that uh there is now no easy
uh way of finding a diplomatic or a
negotiated solution i know the house
would have preferred that but i think
it's going to be very difficult as it
were to construct an off-ramp
for vladimir putin and we are now in a
logic where we must simply do everything
we can collectively to ensure that
vladimir putin fails and fails
comprehensively in ukraine mohammad
jason thank you very much mr speaker the
majority of my constituents are sickened
and furious
that the prime minister
broke the laws that they followed
putting their lives on hold
missing out on big life events and even
losing the chance to say goodbye to
loved ones to protect the nhs and save
lives
does the prime minister agree with my
constituents robert who believes that
law breakers should not be lawmakers
uh mr speaker i apologize uh profusely
to again again to particularly to all
those uh who lost uh loved ones and i
know how uh uh painful it it has been
but i repeat what i've said i believe
that the job of the government now is to
get on uh with delivering on the
priorities of the country uh at a
difficult time
brendan clark smith
you mr speaker and uh i know the prime
minister has offered his wholehearted
apology for the fixed penalty notice he
received which i very much welcome but
can i encourage the prime minister not
to take any lectures from the labour
party opposite bearing in mind the
number of fbns their previous cabinet
received and yes speed does kill
or of course on this occasion the fpns
that the labour party and smp did not
receive does the prime minister agree
with me that everybody should be equal
under the law
well mrs i yeah of course i agree with
that mr speaker but the issue here today
let's be frank is uh is what i did and
what i got wrong and i i renew my
apologies
dear manchester evil
thank you very much uh mr speaker the
prime minister accepted
the health secretary's resignation for
breaking guidance
covered gardens not cobid laws
the prime minister then accepted allegra
stratton's resignation for joking that
the parties that were
so
frequent in downing street were actually
a business event he's now using her joke
as his defense
why is he holding himself
to lower standards
than he held the people whose
resignations he accepted
[Applause]
mr speaker all i can say is that uh i
apologize uh for what i got wrong uh and
i've explained to the house why i spoke
in the house as i
as i did and what i want to do is to get
on with the the job of the government
in taking this country forward and and
that is what we're going to do
thank you mr speaker i dare say that
every member of this house can bring to
mind their own john robinson perhaps
several
and though you would not know it
i also think that most members of this
house know that justice and mercy
and humility also go hand in hand the
fact no
by many who watch these proceedings too
in asking us
to forgive him
on behalf of all of those john robinsons
we represent
my right honourable friend could not
have made a more humble apology
but what i want to say
is that justice
leading into mercy relies on a very very
old-fashioned concept and that is
repentance
what assurance can he give us
that nothing of this kind will ever
happen again
i i i thank him for what he has said and
uh i i'm heartily
sorry as i have said and i i
i wish it had not uh happened and i wish
i i wish that things have been totally
different what i can what i could have
already done as the house will know is
taking steps uh to change the way we do
things in uh in number 10 but that in
itself is is not enough i accept full
responsibility myself for my actions
thank you mr speaker
the prime minister's spouse's apology to
the nation is pathetic
he told brief families in downing street
last year that he had done everything
possible to save their loved ones
now
he's been fined for breaking his own
laws
illustrating just how soft the tories
have become on crime
and does the prime minister accept his
words ring hollow
for those of us who have lost the loved
ones
i i
repeat what i've said and i and i know
that the honourable gentleman has
experienced bereavement during the uh
the pandemic and i'm
sorry for his loss and uh i i repeat my
apologies uh for what happened in number
ten
michael fabrica mr speaker i was
desperately sad to hear about
my constituency constituent john
robinson
my own best friend
his mother died in hospital
and he wasn't able to see her
and i do recall of course that the prime
minister's mother
also died during that covid crisis
we've all suffered
from these heart-wrenching tragedies
and none of us should forget it
but i just want to ask a quick question
if i may regarding the ukraine
the prime minister has announced that
he's going to provide new modern mobile
ground to air missile systems
how will we be able to train the
ukrainians during this war situation so
that they can be put into use before
it's too late
i i i thank my right on a friend i
repeat my
condolences to uh his friend and
i
just tell him on the the star streak and
other systems that we're we're using
that we've uh
supplying to the ukrainians ukrainians
are now being trained as as you can
imagine outside uh the theater of the
immediate theater of
conflict murray river
mr speaker the prime minister genuinely
doesn't seem to understand how he got
his fine or what he did to break the law
he wrote what an utter nonsense
does the prime minister understand that
if a man is so incompetent that he can't
understand his own rules is he also a
man who can't understand the public's
challenges the pace and scale of the
soaring cost of living yeah yeah yeah
i i thank her and that's exactly why the
government is focused on uh those issues
uh that's what we need to get on with
it's dealing with the aftershocks of
kobe the impact of the uh ukrainian
crisis on on fuel prices and on
inflation that is where uh we are
focused 100 percent
yes someone needs to have the courage to
get rid of the leader
the leader who is sitting in the kremlin
and causing the deaths of tens of
thousands of innocent people and maybe i
only speak for myself i say it in all
humility
i'm not going to give the satisfaction
about death's head tyrant of removing a
british prime minister who was given an
apology
who was working night and day to save
thousands of lives you went downstairs
to thank his staff who were doing the
same job
he has apologized let's show some
compassion
[Applause]
i i thank him very much for what he has
said i just want to say one important
thing it is very very important uh in
this ukrainian crisis uh that we do not
make it an objective to remove uh the
russian leader or to change politics in
and this is about protecting the people
of ukraine that is what we are doing and
uh putin will try to frame it as a as a
struggle between him and the west we
cannot accept that this is about his
brutal attack on the people of ukraine
yeah i'm charlie
thank you mr speaker here we are again
talking about the prime minister and his
misdemeanors
is it frustrating for all of us on both
sides of the house that we have to still
be here but the prime minister has led
us this merry dance nobody else the
prime minister
please after all the apologies today
prime minister resign because we have
had enough the country deserves better
well i i thank her very much i must
respectfully uh if if you'll forgive me
uh direct her to what i've already said
mark pritchard
can i recognize the prime minister's
contrition
humility
and apology
before the house
uh today
can i thank him as chair of the
all-party parliamentary group on ukraine
for his leadership on ukraine
and pass on the facts of people across
party from the rada the parliament in
ukraine for his leadership over this
conflict and can i encourage him
to steal the resolve and the resilience
of our eu partners and nato members that
think perhaps if putin gains the east of
ukraine and southern ukraine he will
stop there is it not the case he'll be
reinvigorated and he will come back for
kiev and perhaps other nato allies on
another day
can i thank him very much for his uh my
honorable friend for his clarity of
thought and his
own leadership on ukraine and i'm afraid
he is entirely right that it is all too
possible that putin will
acquire fresh momentum in the east uh
and uh we could see i'm i'm afraid a uh
resurgence of russian attacks
joanna chubb thank you very much mr
speaker it's quite difficult to follow
the prime minister's excuses but i think
what he's saying today
is that he didn't think he was breaking
any covert rules because the gathering
respect of which he was fined was
covered by a workplace exemption
if that is correct then why did he pay
the fixed penalty notice fine
why didn't he refuse to do so and set
out his defense in court
can i suggest that he didn't do so
because he was afraid of his track
record to date before the courts of both
this jurisdiction and indeed my own in
scotland
because mr speaker judges and juries
like our constituents tend to have a
pretty good handle
on issues of credibility and reliability
so that's why the prime minister didn't
take his chances with the court isn't
that correct
mr speaker i i've explained that uh
i i believed that the event was uh in
conformity with the rules that has
turned out not to be true i i humbly and
sincerely accept that robert halford
thank you mr speaker i thank the prime
minister for what he said in this house
today i think it will mean something to
my constituents of harlow and he
mentioned that one of the great
challenges that the government is facing
is about the the cost of living and and
could he build on the work of the
chancellor of the spring
a statement to further to take further
measures to cut the cost of living
perhaps either getting rid of the green
levees that act as 25 of our energy
bills or at least introducing a
downwards escalator so when the
international energy price goes high the
uh green levels would be reduced
i i thank him very much i know that he's
campaigned uh assiduously uh for his uh
constituents and for the whole country
to reduce the burden particularly fuel
costs and uh i know that he would have
been uh pleased by the the chancellor of
my round from the chancellor's decision
to cut 5p off fuel duty a record uh cut
and i know that we will do uh more as as
soon as we can to help people with the
cost of living
mr speaker
is the prime minister aware that those
of us known him for a long time
uh know that he spent his life
apologizing humbly
um and uh we those of us knowing don't
dislike him or hate him
but we are waiting for signs that he's
mending his ways that he's changing how
he operates and can i just say
if he thinks that deflecting on to some
of the good work he's done in ukraine
we'll
we'll balance what he said to this house
can i remind him he's got
key links with washington i still have
but in washington in in berlin in paris
his behavior here has really undermined
his status and his credibility worldwide
[Applause]
i i thank him uh very much i i
i in no way wish to uh deflect from uh
the gravity of the uh the the fine that
i've received and uh and i i want to
stress the uh again the apology but i
simply must disagree very profoundly
with what he's just said
morris
mr speaker i've heard the prime minister
apologize countless times in this chain
today
i'm man enough to accept that mr speaker
but it's about a matter of trust
and this prime minister
this prime minister i trusted him to see
us through brexit he did
i trusted him to see us through the
kobit epidemic
and very much he nearly died of himself
and he did and you know something else
the whole world
just said i've got to say it's going to
be through the church not through the
smp please david
i totally agree mr speaker but you know
something else mr speaker and this is
the most important
this prime minister is leading the world
against putin's aggression
and the g7 leaders are respected for
that and more to the point so does
president biden so i just want to say to
this prime minister prime minister will
you carry on please leading this country
[Applause]
uh i thank you very much for the the the
answer to that is uh is yes i will uh
but that in no way uh means that i i
wish to mitigate uh what uh the uh the
offense that i've uh
been found guilty of uh not uh nor to
nor to under in any way uh undermine the
importance of my
apology alex clinic
speaker my constituent jason greene
wrote to me today to tell me how his
wife lost his mother suddenly last year
but couldn't travel to be with her
father who himself died three days later
because they were following the law
they didn't get to the funerals either
because they were abiding by the law he
doesn't forgive the prime minister he
says the apologies are too late and the
prime minister should resign what's he
got to say to jason and his family
well done
i i apologize again to not just to jason
but to the families of all those who
lost loved ones uh during uh kobed and i
i repeat what i've i've told the house
earlier i look challenged thank you mr
speaker i thank the prime minister for
his statement and for the way in which
uh he made it
president zielinski said yesterday that
the conflict in ukraine has moved to the
second phase
now we all recognize that the balance
between offensive and defensive weapons
is very very fine
as the conflict continues to develop
will my right honourable friend continue
to review where that line
stands i thank him very much he's asking
an extremely important question
and
the answer is that i don't think any uh
nato uh country any western country uh
wants to see its forces or its uh or our
own uh weaponry directly engaged uh with
uh russia uh what we want to see that's
to say with uh with the use of our own
uh troops and personnel uh but it is i
think holy legitimate and morally right
to give the ukrainians the the equipment
with which to protect themselves
thank you uh mr speaker
i
the prime minister has come here today
and to some respects i would have very
much welcomed an entire statement about
what has been happening in ukraine
and it does feel a little bit like uh he
seeks cover um in in
which is which is shameful
but the truth of the matter is is that
on the cost of living crisis on on all
the issues that we face both
domestically and
in foreign affairs the fundamental of
whether people can trust our politics
matters
and if the people in this room do not
ask for the prime minister to bear the
rigor of the things that are put in
place to ensure that leaders cannot
mislead this house
if they don't walk through the lobby to
do that
they are setting a dangerous precedent
so through you mr speaker i won't speak
to the prime minister i speak to them
what i ask the prime minister is shall i
look forward to this same statement at
the next fine and to stretch the
metaphor of the
speeding fines after three fines on the
road for speeding one has one's driving
license removed from them so at what
point in his fine history
will he see sense
i i thank her very much and uh i want to
repeat what i've said already i i
apologize for the fine i received i
can't comment about any uh hypothetical
situations
i know that many in abercromwy have
written to me about their upset at
events but i know that many in
abercromway 2 will have heard the prime
minister's apology today and will
welcome it
i welcome it indeed perhaps we all have
a hope that there's forgiveness in our
future and not just punishment for our
past
i also welcome the fact that the prime
minister talked about his obligations so
could he please update the house then on
his commitment to strengthening the
united kingdom of great britain and
northern ireland please
uh thank you very much i thank him for
all the work that he does to
protect and support the uh the union uh
with great britain and northern ireland
and as he knows it's under a lot of
pressure caused by uh the uh the
northern irish protocol which i i
believe is uh undermining the balance of
the good friday uh agreement and we will
have to uh to sort it out mr speaker
there's several roberts
prime minister
debases himself he debates his office
he debates his government
and he debases those who seek to defend
him he is a millstone around his party's
neck
the welsh government's welsh
conservatives
18-page local election manifesto
makes
zero reference to the prime minister
they don't appear like a number of his
own backbenchers
to want to be associated with him
can he explain why
uh mr speaker i think what they probably
want to uh have in in wales is uh better
government and to to avoid uh
and and that and i i would think they're
campaigning for the investment in the
nhs uh that i'm afraid that both welsh
labor and uh the amply cumbria have
failed to deliver
that's leo
thank you mr speaker i thank the prime
minister for his fulsome apology today
given that does the prime minister agree
that the priority for this house and
this government must be the very real
challenges facing our country
particularly the russian invasion of
ukraine and the cost of living pressures
caused by covert and worsened by
russia's war on ukraine and coming from
poland last week helping with ukrainian
child refugees may i pass on the
widespread respect and admiration with
which his leadership on ukraine is
helped
can i thank her very much for what she
has been doing to help uh refugees in uh
in poland and we talked about it uh the
other day i know many other members
across the house are doing uh doing the
same and i thank them all
lloyd russell
mr speaker
i share the prime minister's thoughts
on ukraine over easter my constituents
collected the morning after pill to send
to ukraine
for women who are being raped by russian
forces
but they're discussed and their
admiration about what is britain's role
in that does not dampen their anger at
the prime minister's actions
you know it was not just the crime
but it was the lie observation and the
fake apologies that god said no no no no
i decide no i'm sorry you can't take my
job you're the backbencher i'm in the
chair just we don't use the word lie
i've explained that earlier and i stand
by it so i'm sure that you withdraw it
immediately
the sentence is not about the prime
minister
but i will withdraw it if you don't like
the word
those are the things that got
geoffrey archer fiona anasanya and chris
hewn kicked out of this place or forced
to resign
now of course i hove no hope on his
front benchers who are tax dodging
russian financial snowflakes but i do
have higher hopes for his backbenchers
so how many
how many backbenchers credibility should
be destroyed in supporting the prime
minister
just say let's try and see if we can
keep it temperate and moderate there was
no individual mention still there for it
was within not what i would expect well
that's where we are prime minister
mr speaker i
i
heard what he said i don't agree with it
uh but and i know what i agree with is
what he said about uh the front bench
david simmons
thank you mr speaker um mr speaker i was
lucky in that on saturday night
i got to hold the hand of my
father-in-law
as he died of complications of covid
so i understand
the anger that many people feel
and
the challenge that we all face when it
comes to the credibility of our
government and the good actions of this
conservative government which i support
and i have to ask my writeable friend
what steps he has in mind
to restore
the moral authority of this government
mr speaker i think the best thing that
the government can do is to continue to
deliver on the promises that we made to
the british people and that is what
we're doing
lucas
thank you very much mr speaker the
respected constitutional historian lord
peter hennessey reminds us that it is
the prime minister who is the guardian
of the ministerial code
what can we do to protect that code when
the person who is entrusted with
guarding it
breaks that code and its overarching
duty to comply with the law and becomes
in the words of lord hennessy a rogue
prime minister you're here
mr speaker i i don't agree with that
characterization and
uh the
uh the i've explained to the house uh
why i spoke as i uh i did and i've
explained and i've apologized for uh for
the mistake that i made
thank you mr speaker
my constituents in search field have
expressed both their satisfaction is how
we are helping the people of ukraine
but also their frustration and anger at
events in number 10.
they also believe that one is not linked
to the other
his contrition over his error is welcome
and i thank him for it
and whilst it was a clear of judgment i
certainly do not believe it's a
resigning matter
if it was
then regardless of ukraine it still
would be
i like many have missed a funeral of a
close friend but i would still have
missed that funeral regardless of the pm
zero because the rules were correct and
his order does not change that
as regards ukraine though could i please
encourage him to continue his efforts
with full vigor
i thank uh him very much and i share the
i understand the frustration and the
anger of his constituents in sedgefield
and uh and i i understand uh perfectly
how they uh they feel i i renew my uh
apologies to them and i
also share what he has to say about
ukraine stella cruz thank you mr speaker
the benches opposite have talked about
repentance the prime minister has
offered us his apology we're being asked
to move on but there's a critical
question for all of us as to whether the
metropolitan police have moved on from
this matter now the prime minister says
that he cannot deal with hypotheticals
but now it has occurred to him what a
party actually is
can he tell us whether he expects more
fines to come yes or no
i i would love to give more commentary
on this but i i've told the house very
clearly that i can't do that until the
investigation is complete
mr speaker um the deputy head of the
ukrainian president's office has said
that the uk
is the leader in defence support for
ukraine
the leader in the anti-war coalition the
leader in sanctions against the russian
aggressor so with russia's offensive in
the donbass beginning the next stage of
putin's appalling invasion can my right
honourable friend assure me that the uk
will remain the leader of international
efforts to support ukraine including
persuading all our friends and allies of
the need to stand up to putin's
outrageous actions yeah i thank him very
much and i i know that the whole house
uh will want and i think that the unity
on this has been important uh we'll want
the uk government to continue to take
that role and we certainly will yes
columbus one
people across these islands had to watch
through care home windows as their loved
ones died parents had to bury their
children without the comfort of their
family around them while that was
happening the prime minister and the
chancellor were partying in downing
street we know he has no respect for the
public but can he show us that he has
some respect just a little bit of
respect for himself and please please
please resign now
i'm
grateful to the uh honorable gentleman i
and i uh understand the feelings of his
uh constituents but i must uh direct him
to what i've said earlier on jacob
thank you mr speaker can i welcome the
prime minister's renewed focus on
nuclear energy and its power to
transform our energy independence does
he also recognize we don't just need
energy independence but also
independence in our foundation
industries like chemicals and steel yeah
yeah
yes indeed i can't congratulate my
honourable friend on his recent marriage
uh by the way
mr speaker and say that uh we certainly
see uh nuclear energy as of vital uh
importance and uh as well of course as
investing in uh new technologies uh
which is why we have we're putting
record investments into our r d 22
billion pounds mr speaker
dave whitson
thank you mr speaker mr speaker the
prime minister broke the laws that he
made laws to protect public health then
repeatedly misled parliament does the
prime minister agree that comments made
by his northern ireland secretary this
morning comparing his fine to a parking
ticket or insulting and when will he do
what the majority of this country wants
and
resign i i i thank her i i look in no
way minimize the importance of uh the
fine i have received as i've said uh
several times this afternoon
richard drax thank you mr speaker we all
have our faults mr speaker and i'm sure
the prime minister would agree
that he has his share of his own but he
also has
many attributes and one of them is
courage
and it took courage to go to ukraine to
stand up for freedom after those people
have been subjected to barbarism
i must take this opportunity to ask my
writable friend will he review the cuts
to our armed forces and ensure that the
future of this country is invested in to
meet this future and very real threat
[Music]
i i thank my honourable friend who is a
valiant campaigner for uh the armed
forces in all their uh guises and quite
rightly mr speaker and it's partly
thanks to the lobbying of himself and
others like him that we've uh uh
increased defense pending by record sums
uh 24 billion pounds and that has
enabled us uh helped us greatly in
helping our ukrainian friends
barbara
keyley speaker
a constituent wrote to me about his
feelings about the downing street
parties good friday was the second
anniversary of the death of his wife a
health care assistant at bolton hospital
who died from clovid
over the 10 days she was ill he was not
able to go with her to hospital or visit
her until just before she died
after she died he had to plan her
funeral alone there was no wake and
after the funeral he had to go back to
an empty home with no support from
family and friends
now it's clear that the party opposite
wants to move on but since his wife died
my constituent tells me he has been
unable to work or to move on or to
grieve i want to ask my constituents
question to the prime minister directly
i followed the law to the letter why
does the government think the laws don't
apply to them
i
want to say again how sorry i am for the
loss of uh her constituent and i
apologize to him personally and and uh
to uh his family all those who who lost
loved ones and it's a measure of the
seriousness with which i take this today
of course uh we think that the law
applies to us of course it does
catherine watched thank you mr speaker
at high altitude one nose starts to
bleed with the er rise in national
insurance more tax than for 70 years our
constituents are crying out for help
whether it's with their energy bills
whether it's with the rents which have
gone up by at least 20 percent in some
parts of my constituency and yet we will
be facing this sort of debate day after
day after day until the prime minister
faces up to responsibility and resigns
all the members here take him out that
is the choice until we actually start
focusing on the things which matter
um
i respectfully say to her i think the
real choice uh that this uh government
this uh house of commons should follow
is getting on with the job of serving
the people uh that we were elected uh to
serve and helping them with the cost of
living that's what we're doing
thank you mr speaker prime minister's
questions on weddings to 8th of december
the prime minister said there was no
party and no covert rules were broken
today he refers to his law breaking as a
mistake can the prime minister explain
to my constituents and indeed to
children across these aisles what the
difference is between a lie and a
mistake yeah yeah
mr speaker i've apologized uh deeply for
what i got wrong and i've explained and
i've explained to the house why i spoke
as i did on that occasion and others
wait dave
many references have been made to the
views of the electorate of this country
and i can tell him that those views are
shared by my constituents as well
so i would ask the prime minister is he
be prepared to take a uh truth detection
test after every prime ministerial
statement
[Music]
i don't know whether the
honourable gentleman is being serious
sir mr speaker uh but i spoke uh in all
good faith to the house and i'll
continue to do so
stephen curry
i do wonder what continued purpose the
prime minister says for the ministerial
code given the frequency with which it's
seemingly broken with impunity
and how can the uk be a credible leader
for liberal democratic values around the
world
whenever basic norms of accountability
are thrown aside save the skin of one
man
the answer to that question is is
staring him uh in the face uh if he
looks at what is happening uh in uh
around the world mr speaker the uk is
continuing to provide moral uh political
diplomatic leadership and as well as
military support and that is what we
will continue to do justin mothers thank
you mr speaker the prime minister would
have us believe he didn't normally break
the law and many of my constituents will
have difficulty accepting that but if we
are to suspend billy for a minute based
on the prime minister's own words he's
telling the world he didn't know what
the rules were so i asked him does he
think someone who doesn't understand the
laws they are bringing in is fit to lead
this country
i i thank him very much i've explained
why uh i i thought that uh the event was
within the rules i apologize very
sincerely joe mora
thank you mr speaker many newcastle
central residents have contacted me to
share precious moments missed charging
me to hold the prime minister to account
they don't accept his apology because mr
speaker you see they thought long and
hard about the difficult decisions they
had to make weighing up the huge
personal costs versus the terrible
consequences of spreading the virus they
made the right decision the prime
minister didn't apparently because he is
too stupid
to understand his own regulations so if
he is so much
stupider than my constituents
why how
can he claim to lead them and the nation
i i thank uh her constituents very much
for what they did uh throughout the
pandemic and it's thanks to people up
and down the country who followed the
rules uh that we've been able to
defeat uh kovid or beat it back in the
way that we have and i i apologize
heartily for what i got wrong
christine jardin
thank you very much mr speaker
i like so many others in this place i'm
sure are profoundly proud of the way in
which the people of this country
stood together
showed the commitment and the resolve
that they did throughout the culvert
crisis and now
are facing a cost of living crisis
and on top of all of that
have thrown their 100 percent baha
support behind the people of ukraine
but it breaks my heart mr speaker that
they have been so badly let down
by the person they looked to to lead
them with the same sort of commitment
and honor as they have shown
so i would ask
whether the prime minister recognizes
that no apology however heartfelt
however genuine can make up for that
loss of faith and that perhaps
it's time he recognizes that the people
of this country
deserve
better yeah
i i thank her very much and i think that
uh
i understand completely the people the
feelings of uh people about uh
kobit about what they did and about the
failings in uh in number 10 but i think
that the job of the government is to get
on and deliver for those very people now
facing the cost of living crisis that
she describes and that is what we're
going to do brother thank you foxcroft
thank you mr speaker prime minister i
personally found that apology shocking
people have lost loved ones and haven't
been able to attend their funerals my
b-tech tutor in performing arts martin
cosgriff sadly passed away from covid he
saw something in the young me who many
felt was destined for nothing and
encouraged me to attend university he
was a fantastic man and is deeply missed
by all his students in the word of one
of his friends we were his children yet
none of us were able to attend his
funeral so what does the prime minister
say to
all of martin's former students from
akron and rosendale college who were
unable to mark the passing of this
influential man
well i i he sounds like a remarkable uh
man uh mr speaker i'm i'm very sorry uh
for her loss
and uh for the loss of all the pupils
that uh that she mentions
so there we are boris johnson in the
commons still answering questions on
partygate he said he paid the fine
apologized and said people expected more
of the prime minister
but again said he did not knowingly
break the rules then raised the issue of
ukraine
as the one he was concentrating on and
in fact it became more a statement
about ukraine
than partygate kia starmer called the
statement a joke
and a half-hearted apology and called
the prime minister a man
without shame
so uh good evening to you from vinicia
in ukraine we'll bring you all the
latest as uh russia begins a renewed
assault on uh eastern ukraine today but
first to those matters at westminster
and the prime minister has apologized to
mps after being fined for breaking a
lockdown rules boris johnson was
speaking after the common speaker
granted mps a vote on whether the prime
minister should be investigated
over claims
he misled